hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the Potter
family godrics Hollow Voldemort on
October 31st 1981. specifically we're
going to be tackling the question of why
James Potter didn't act as his own
Secret Keeper instead entrusting the
responsibility with known rant Peter
Pettigrew join me as we dive deep into
the fidelius charm and the role of The
Secret Keeper in the tragic events that
led to the downfall of James and Lily
Potter let's get started we all know how
devastating it was when the Potters were
killed leaving baby Harry as the only
Survivor it was a defining moment in the
story of the boy who lived and many fans
have debated the events that led to
their untimely deaths to understand what
happened we need to take a closer look
at the fidelius charm this powerful
spell is used to keep secrets hidden and
secure and it relies on the presence of
an individual known as a Secret Keeper
but what happened when the Secret Keeper
is not the best choice what if choosing
differently could have saved lives do
you answer these questions we first need
to properly grasp what the fidelius
charm is and what being a Secret Keeper
really means
imagine a spell so powerful it can hide
the location of an object or person from
prying eyes that's the fidelius charm
this ancient and complex enchantment is
one of the most formidable defensive
spells in The Wizarding World the
fidelius charm works by confining The
Secret in this instance the location of
the Potter Cottage within the soul of a
designated Secret Keeper Only The Secret
Keeper possesses the knowledge of the
Hidden location while all others remain
completely unaware think of it as an
invisible magical lock guarding the
secret with an unbreakable Bond
but as powerful as the fidelius charm is
its effects are useless without a
reliable Secret Keeper selecting the
right Secret Keeper is no easy task and
the task becomes even more crucial when
life and death are at stake it requires
absolute trust and loyalty as the person
chosen holds the key to the hidden
secrets the identity of the Secret
Keeper is known only to the person who
cast the charm and the Secret Keeper
themselves The Potter's decision now
let's Dive Into the Heart of the matter
why did James Potter choose Peter
Pettigrew as his secret keeper instead
of being his own it's a question that is
haunted fans for years let me start by
addressing the first part of the
question why Peter
lifelong friends James Sirius Remus and
Peter the Marauders were tight-knit and
their friendship ran deep they shed
Adventures mischief and secrets during
their time at Hogwarts forming an
unbreakable Bond James and Peter were
lifelong friends and they really didn't
have any reason not to trust Peter a
diversionary tactic for those unaware
James Potter actually initially chose
Sirius Black as a Secret Keeper in fact
Cirrus was the man who most believed to
be the Potter's Secret Keeper however
serious thinking that Voldemort might
Target him suggested that they choose
Pettigrew instead the following excerpt
from Sirius addresses this Lily and
James only made you secret keeper
because I suggested it I thought it was
the perfect plan Voldemort would be sure
to come after me but never dreamed
they'd use a weak talentless thing like
you it must have been the finest moment
of your miserable life telling Voldemort
you could hand him The Potters by
selecting Peter the seemingly least
likely candidate they hope to throw off
the scent
unforeseen betrayal after being made
Secret Keeper it didn't take Peter
Pettigrew long to reveal his true colors
in one Infamous Act of cowardice and
disloyalty revealing the location of the
Potter Cottage to Voldemort Peter was no
friend of James but instead a cowardly
Death Eater sympathizer who went to
wherever he believed the power to be
Peter's cowardice inevitably cost James
and Lily Potter and their lives
effectively orphaning the boy who live
alternative secret Keepers provided that
the downfall of The Potters was almost
exclusively due to their choice of
Secret Keeper I can't help but ask
myself what if someone else was chosen
and who better to leave the secret with
than the Potter family themselves would
James have survived if he had chosen
himself as The Secret Keeper what if he
conjured up the courage to trust in his
own ability to protect his family
the first thing I'll mention is that
there's a fair bit of ambiguity with
regards to who's actually qualified to
be a secret keeper in the Deathly
Hallows it's revealed that bill Weasley
is the secret keeper for Shell Cottage
and Arthur Weasley is the secret keeper
for the burrow given that these are
their places of residence it proves I
think that a person who lives in the
house being protected can also be
eligible to be its Secret Keeper by this
logic James Potter would have been a
suitable candidate to be the secret
keeper for their Cottage in godrics
Hollow one possible reason why James may
have opted not to assume the role of
Secret Keeper for his own home could be
due to the fact that he himself needed
to remain hidden from potential threats
it speculated that the fidelius charm
makes the dwelling untraceable through
means such as owls and Patronus
communication and in this regard Arthur
and Bill Weasley had the advantage of
Potter watch to stay on top of
ever-changing events in The Wizarding
World this resource was not available
during the first war meaning that if
James were to serve as his own secret
keeper and go into hiding The Potters
would not only be untraceable but also
entirely disconnected from The Wizarding
World
alternatively James could have chosen to
appoint himself as Secret Keeper and
disclose the secret to a trusted
confidante who would act as the
intermediary between the potters and the
Order of the Phoenix
Sirius would be the obvious choice here
however if something were to happen to
him The Potters would once again meet
the risk of separation from Wizarding
Society it's also worth pointing out
that there is a bit of a difference
between the way Bill and Arthur use the
charm versus James's potential use in
the case of shell Cottage in the borough
the fidelius charm protected the
prophecy and its occupants by extension
however in the unique case of The
Potters the purpose of the fidelius
charm cast upon them was slightly
different its main objective was to
safeguard the Family itself rather than
placing emphasis on their humble Cottage
this Revelation is discussed by
Professor Flitwick in the Prisoner of
Azkaban as he imparts wisdom on the
inner workings of the fidelius charm as
long as the Secret Keeper refused to
speak you know who could search the
village where Lily and James were
staying for years and never find them
not even if he had his nose pressed
against their sitting room window
the intention behind casting the
fideliest charm upon the Potter's
Cottage in godric's Hollow seems to have
been focused on concealing the family
rather than solely isolating the
property this could be attributed to the
fact that the Potters had no need or
desire to come into contact with
individuals outside their trusted circle
on the other hand the Weasleys being
active members of the order required
interaction with fellow members leading
them to protect only the locations of
their homes under the charm what's also
worth mentioning is that no one truly
knows if hiding one's own person via the
fidelius charm is even possible while
James Potter may have technically been
eligible to serve as the secret keeper
for the cottage the ambiguity
surrounding with the charm protected the
property or the Family itself coupled
with the obscurity surrounding the
implications of the latter leaves it all
a bit too wide open why not Dumbledore
while we're on the topic I think the
elephant in the room needs to be
addressed why not Dumbledore why not
select the most powerful wizard of all
time who is also your major Ally to hold
your secret for you Dumbledore to me
seems like an obvious choice as Secret
Keeper he wouldn't have even needed to
be secretive about it Dumbledore's high
profile but it wouldn't have mattered
Voldemort himself feared Dumbledore so
the prospect of him being taken down or
targeted for information was extremely
unlikely Voldemort's fear of Dumbledore
is even referenced by McGonagall but
you're different everyone knows you're
the only one you know all right
Voldemort was frightened of in the
Prisoner of Azkaban it's even revealed
that Dumbledore offered to take on the
responsibility James Potter told
Dumbledore that black would die rather
than tell where they were that black was
planning to go into hiding himself and
yet Dumbledore remained worried I
remember him offering to be the Potter's
Secret Keeper himself
this means that even though Dumbledore
offered James Potter's blind trust in
Sirius Black and his friends whom he
deeply trusted was his eventual downfall
Dumbledore was close with James but he
wasn't one of the Marauders and I guess
James felt that he could only trust his
friends to the extent required I think
that one of the main reasons for James
not selecting Dumbledore is that
Dumbledore had recently formed a
relationship with the defecting Death
Eater Severus Snape the Snape came to
Dumbledore when he learned that Harry
and the Potters were the target of
Voldemort's attack which presumably
prompted the use of the fidelius charm
in the first place this means that by
this point Dumbledore had accepted that
Snape had switched sides however his new
relationship with Snape may have
instilled doubt in his other allies
allies like James Potter ultimately they
decided to go with someone that they
were completely familiar with and
unfortunately their misjudgment of Peter
pettigrew's character was their ultimate
downfall my closing thought on this
matter is that it really could have been
avoided they could have chosen almost
any other Secret Keeper and things would
have turned out fine furthermore it was
a strange decision to hide the Potters
in such plain sight a big house in
godric's Hollow seems like a strange
place for a family being hunted down by
Voldemort himself
and that's it for this video what do you
think had this thought ever occurred to
you please let me know down in the
comment section below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live